hey everyone with Christmas right around
the corner I thought an updated video
that I made last year in which I gave my
top 10 4k blu-rays of 2018 when I first
got my Ultra HD player
I wanted to buy as many films as
possible to show up the new upgraded
picture quality in HDR but I didn't
really know where to start
4k titles are still really really pricey
and at 20 pound a pop it can be
expensive collecting them especially is
this not really a reliable list of what
the best looking tiles are so to get you
the best bang for your buck throughout
this video we're gonna be discussing our
list of the best looking movies and the
projector to watch them on with that out
of the way I just want to give a huge
thank you for quick in this video I'm
definition from heavy spoilers now let's
get into our top 10 okay so just to make
sure we don't miss anything in case you
completely new to the format and you
just want a quick rundown of the prior
top 10 titles of last year our list was
made up of Pacific Rim life prometheus
Avengers infinity war passengers
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 the
Avengers of the revenant Lucy and Blade
Runner 2049 if you pick up any of those
titles you won't be disappointed as yet
they're just absolutely phenomenal for
2019 though I was blown away by our
first entry at more engines and I feel
like this film was very underrated in
cinemas and in the home theater setting
definitely packs a punch this is a
perfect picture as the movie was shot in
8k and finished with the 4k di so
everything throughout it just looks
outstanding there's a crispness that
really packs a punch and instantly upon
its release it became one of the must
have titles this is how the movie was
supposed to look and I think many will
gain a new appreciation for with the 4k
blu-ray so yeah definitely pick that up
next up is Dunkirk I actually stupidly
emitted this from my last top 10
countdown so it has to be on this one
the movie is absolutely phenomenal and
whether you're watching on a TV or the
projector that I'll be talking about in
just a bit this is a complete knockout
film for the most in IMAX everything
stands out here this sand grains are so
detailed that you could probably count
them one by one and the rich ocean and
sunset are the Spitfires fly over feels
like it could be a post
the 4k blu-ray is a new way to watch the
movie and it feels like a truly
cinematic experience and the upgraded
format this is a must-have and one of
the best entries on the ultra HD market
next up is Aquaman though it was
released with the 2k di it doesn't
suffer in the slightest because of it
with the huge epic IMAX scenes and
incredible textures and colors the movie
really stands out on the format given
both the HDR 10 and Dolby vision
treatment the movie pops in a way that
you just don't get with a standard
blu-ray the first time I saw the
characters travel to Atlantis I was just
completely mesmerized by the beaming
beacons of light the detail in the ocean
surroundings and I really couldn't
believe how good the film looked in
Dolby vision especially this movie is a
wash of colors that stand out and the
film completely knocks out of the park
with its gorgeous vistas and settings
we're not really doing this list in any
order but out of the disks here this is
probably one of the top three and is a
must-have for anyone looking to get into
the UHD format our next entry is glass
now this was a disappointing film for me
due to the fact that I'd waited so long
for a fully fledged sequel to
unbreakable however what isn't a letdown
is the film on Ultra HD blu-ray the
detail here is absolutely insane and at
points the film looks better than real
live due to its incredible textures and
environments the movie yet it just looks
phenomenal
and this should be no surprise as it is
released here in its native 4k this
makes the filmic demo worthy and if like
me you were disappointed in the overall
movie then I definitely recommend that
you revisit it to see what you're
missing okay so before we get into the
rest of our list it's time to discuss
the best projector in the market right
now and that is the BenQ or w 2700 thank
you send us this out for review and if
you've been following my channel for a
while then you'll know that I don't do
brand deals or tie-ins this is the first
time that I've actually been sent
something out to review as normally I
just turn companies down because I don't
really want to push products that I
don't believe in but yep this is
something that I genuinely think that
home theater enthusiasts need to get we
weighed up everything from the overall
price quality and build and if you're
just starting
then this is by far the best projector
to pick up the W 2700 uses cinematic
color technology and supports DCI p3
which is the u.s. movie industry color
standard the projector is relatively
small measuring 38 centimeters across
and just weighing in at 4.2 kilograms
thank you stated in their marketing
material that it can sit nicely in any
room and it definitely feels that way me
my wife put it on our bedside table and
projected it against the opposite wall
and it was pretty much silent throughout
the entire run of all the movies that we
watched on it it can be mounted on a
ceiling used in rear projection as well
and it will pretty much fit in with any
room which makes a great addition to the
house I have tried a lot of projectors
in the past but they were either
eyesores or just really clunky to fit
somewhere whereas this integrates with
most rooms really well it does get a bit
hot from time to time as you'd expect
but that's probably the only downside to
it there's also a wealth of settings so
you can set the projector up for any
environment and get the best picture
possible dunkirk looked absolutely
astounding on this and I was completely
blown away by just how lifelike
everything looked aquaman is well was a
knockout and even regular TV shows look
phenomenal through the technology that
BenQ have here you can manually adjust
the lens and picture or just
automatically do it through the
projector the colors are brilliant and
that standard settings the picture still
looks outstanding of course you can
adjust the picture settings for your
room and so on but the W 2700
automatically handles all of the HDR
work for you it automatically switches
to the picture setting and I'm normally
someone who buys a TV then spends hours
going through all of the settings and
getting it right for my room but out of
the box this is really really good
there's color contrast and outstanding
sharpness here that provides you with
the home cinema experience that you've
been looking for
I really can't overstate how impressed I
was with this everything just works
instinctively the projector scales
really well and even on standard
definition content things still at
breathtaking in my opinion for 2019 this
is definitely the projector that you
need to pick up right now and with its
price overall quality and capabilities
this is the one that we recommend if you
want the best movie experience at home
so without the way up next in our list
is Jurassic world - fallen Kingdom which
comes with Dolby vision and with this
switched on the film looks absolutely
incredible the surroundings dinosaurs
and character detail really stand out
here making it a brilliant adventure
this was a pretty mad experience the
first time I watched it but in the
updated format it really stands out
delivering the true experience that I
think the creative team behind it were
going for though it has a 2k di it still
looks amazing and is a definite must buy
if you want some outstanding picture
quality next on our list is spider-man
into the spider verse and it's no
surprise that this won the Oscar for
best animation as with its 4k release
it's easy to see why the film comes with
Dolby vision and a range of colors that
actually make the image look 3d at
several points I was blown away by just
how much detail was put into the frame
here and as with most 4k releases you
begin to notice things that you missed
or never picked up on which is
especially true here even though
everything in it is artificial the
colors are incredible and before
purchasing it I was worried that they
wouldn't be able to capture the lifelike
colors that we see in real life but that
really isn't the case
electricity looks phenomenal and the
kaleidoscopic range that is laced across
the screen is just breathtaking this is
again a must-have and easily in the top
three of the list up next is the Warner
Brothers Batman set now I know this is
kind of cheating as it is for movies but
you do want to pick up this entire set
when I heard that Michael Keaton Val
Kilmer and George Clooney were coming to
the 4k format I was a bit apprehensive I
knew it would be a must-have for me
because I'm a massive Batman fan but I
didn't know if we would start to see
behind the curtain with a picture
upgrade however I wasn't disappointed at
all and the movies look better than
they've ever been the 4k di makes each
one really stand out and I can't
emphasize how much this is an upgrade
over the prior versions of the films I
used to stay away from all the movies
because of grain which I personally can
find to be slightly over-the-top on all
the titles like that's just a personal
preference and have gotten used to it
but I do tend to prefer a crystal-clear
picture however that comes with this
release and the entire set looks
excellent the restoration is
mind-blowing and misses a must by now
our next entry is actually a bit
surprising
so Avengers endgame was almost on this
list until I saw ant-man released just a
couple of months ago what the movie
looks absolutely amazing given the full
screen treatment this really stands out
no matter what television or projector
you watch it on and the HTR brings
absolutely everything to life the small
character makes a big impact and this
might be a bold thing to say but the 4k
release is probably the best-looking MCU
movie on the format' if you've
overlooked this because it's not one of
the big Marvel titles then I definitely
recommend that you go back and pick this
up as it's one of the best-looking Ultra
HD blu-ray is out there on the market go
buy it now because yet you will not be
disappointed and I can't overstate
enough how good-looking this movie is ok
so once the Lion King paled in
comparison to the original the 4k Ultra
HD release it definitely doesn't stand
in its shadow this is an absolutely
outstanding looking disc and it's
probably one of the best looking films
that I've ever seen every hair detail
and texture on the animal stands out
here and it brings the characters to
life in a way that you don't really get
on lower formats this is a pixel perfect
release and at times I was lost in how
photorealistic this looks this is demo
worthy and is a must own for anyone
looking for a new film to pick up and
lastly is Leon though this was released
in the mid 90s the movie looks like it
was shot yesterday this is just an
incredible restoration that really
brings the film to life in a way that
was lost on previous releases you really
don't get better than this and initially
this only got one release that made it
shoot up and priced you to all the
collectors being after it however right
now it's been re-released again with
added art cards in a special edition
boxset for 20 pound you need to pick
this up trust me I can't stress enough
how much you have to buy this as it's a
must-have purchase that really showcases
what the format can be out when it's at
its best this is a must buy especially
for the price and with Christmas year
you deserve to treat yourself and a
that's our list now obviously I'd love
to hear your top 10
your favorite movies of the air were
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out
our breakdown of the last big movie of
the air the rise of Skywalker we go
about everything that you need to know
about the film and its ending so it's
definitely worth checking out after this
you want to come chat to me after the
video that makes you follow me into
where our definition yte or head over to
my discord server which should be linked
in the description below we drop videos
on there early so if you want to see
stuff before anyone else and that's the
best place to be it's free to join and
we have an awesome community so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
Joker which is one of our favorite
movies of the last year and all you have
to do to be in with the chance of
winning is like the video make 'shy
subscribe to the channel and leave your
thoughts on the list in the comment
section below the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of January
and the cell be shipped out from the end
whoever gets the prize it's the best of
luck to everyone who takes part this is
a channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe
huge thank you for taking the time to
watch this I've been definition you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]